maxim neuss bei pixum und ist nicht nur
maximal bis jetzt auch bei punkt
tatsächlich wie ist das passiert
zufällig bin im suhler straße begegnet
und hat gesagt du bist doch max und
neuss und hast du nicht lust bongo zu
freestylen in der stadt quasi unter dem
bin ich dann okay
über diese geschichte wir besprechen und
natürlich über noch viel mehr vor allen
dingen über eure fragen
postet sie hier unter dem video als
kommentare oder klickt auch instrumental
fällt dann erscheint direkt neben button
zum video upload das heißt video fragen
sind auch willkommen und wir freuen uns
auf eure fragen und einen fragen lotto 1
ein wortspiel und so weiter so maximal
bis dann bleibt dran